i'm a big fan of the found family trope
there's something so heartwarming about
watching complete strangers finding a
place to belong by sticking with each
other it's the basic underlying
principle of practically every superhero
or vigilante team marvel's guardians of
the galaxy builds off this premise to
deliver an incredible story about what
comes after the found family trope as
anyone who is a part of a family can
tell you the regular struggle to
maintain those bonds is what really
takes effort and that's at the heart of
guardians of the galaxy a game that says
that a family once found is worth
fighting for
gardeners of the galaxy
what no
rocket so i let groot fill out the
paperwork i fixed it with an addendum
not the most well-known heroes you could
hire but definitely in the top five of
most awesome names guardians of the
galaxy picks up following the creation
of the team all of whom have some sort
of history with one another the origin
story has already occurred and the
player is now catching up on what the
characters already know though i can see
how this setup could confuse players who
aren't familiar with peter quill gamora
rocket groot and drax the setup
ultimately works to the game's benefit
guardians of the galaxy regularly moves
beyond familiarity digging into the
wonderfully bizarre cosmic side of
marvel's universe all of which is so
absurdly alien
so
this is the thing you had to do
come to the observation deck to look at
the rift
no
i came to honor the memory of my family
and yet it's all very human too and
that's why it works so well these might
not be the guardians you're familiar
with but the issues that they're
attempting to deal with and overcome are
all deeply relatable the same can be
said for the increasingly strange
assortment of allies and enemies the
guardians meet you latch onto their
issues and pay attention to them because
they're the parts of the story that make
the most sense from a human perspective
that more than anything captures the
sensation of being peter quill aka
star-lord a human who finds himself
regularly exploring a galaxy far removed
from the goings-on of earth and yet as
an earthling is ideally suited for
navigating these galactic issues because
he can bring out the innate humanity of
these aliens for what it's worth nikki
totally saved my butt she handled
herself really well you have every
reason be proud of her coming from you
peter it's worth extraordinarily little
you apply peter's human perspective via
your own with choice driven dialogue
you'll regularly be presented with
opportunities where peter can respond to
conversations in multiple ways your
available choices pop up for a limited
time and those around you usually don't
stop talking while peter is thinking
presenting the opportunity to say
nothing at all sometimes though missing
a chance to speak is a risk worth taking
as holding out to respond can
occasionally allow you to gather more
information about how everyone is
feeling by listening to the conversation
or being an evasive woman wait woman
that's the nicest thing you've ever
called me
i told peter quill i would try that is
not the point
the insect woman has embarrassed you a
warning to discuss it is your right
i appreciate you saying that drax
the act of listening to someone as
opposed to just hearing the words is a
big part of the game's narrative core
the overarching campaign of guardians of
the galaxy isn't affected by the choices
you make but individual relationships
and certain story developments are
influenced and the best outcomes only
occur if you listen to what people are
saying and reply in a way that responds
to their concerns often times that
results in immediate consequences but
there are a handful of opportunities
where your choices early on can have
long-standing effects and it's deeply
gratifying to see the game reward you in
later conflicts for being a good
listener throughout the course of the
campaign knew this would come in handy
where'd you get a nova pass key
nikki gave it to me to keep it away from
her mom that campaign sees the guardians
struggling to pay off a massive debt in
order to avoid being arrested a task
that ultimately gets the five
self-described heroes for hire tangled
up in a galaxy-wide threat this game
isn't reinventing the traditional
superhero story and you'll likely
foresee several of its twists and turns
but it's well written and well sold by
the fairly impressive motion capture and
superb voice talent to bring life to an
otherwise by the book story we cannot
present this pathetic creature to the
monster queen of sect off 9 she'll laugh
at us
maybe we can use it as bait
i knew those slumpers wouldn't work what
my thumpers are state-of-the-art muscle
head's the one who rushed to the first
thing that came through the door
my head is not made of muscle between
the bouts of story there are a lot of
baddies to shoot from murderous jello to
an assortment of super villains the
guardians face a variety of threats
throughout the game each post seemingly
encourages you to approach the threat in
different ways a target carrying a
shield suggests you need to find a means
of flanking them while a more nimble
beast-like enemy may seemingly prove
difficult to attack if you can't pin
them down i say seemingly because it's
an illusionary variety and one that is
easily seen through after a few hours
with the game early on the game
advertises each guardian as uniquely
qualified for responding to these
specific threats but none of that is
necessary every enemy can be damaged by
all 5 guardians so you can just as
easily spam the same attacks over and
over to win a fight despite each
guardian unlocking four abilities i
never found myself having to use more
than their first two to overcome a fight
and so fights ultimately devolve into
ever longer grind fest as the number of
enemies grow more plentiful and their
health bars extend ever longer the game
includes multiple difficulties including
a custom level where you can adjust
practically every aspect of combat quick
time events and dialogue choices to
incredible detail you could crank up the
game's difficulty in order to create
more of an incentive to use each
guardian to the best of your ability at
risk of a squad wipe for nearly every
encounter if you want an extra challenge
that said doing so isn't intrinsically
increasing the level of strategy needed
to beat the game it's simply making
enemies into harder hitting bullet
sponges so fights become longer not
tougher
in the event a fight wasn't going my way
i could easily turn the tides with a
team huddle a mechanic i love but which
feels underutilized why have you called
us off the battlefield
our enemies are melting before us the
huddle mechanic is like the guardian's
ultimate ability charging throughout
combat and best safe for when all seems
dire or we want to lay on the damage and
finish off a tough opponent it sees
peter call his allies to him allowing
them to group up and express how they're
feeling about the fight you then get a
choice of what to say to inspire the
group with the team being fully revived
and their ability cooldowns reset if you
respond to your allies concerns
it is magnificent drax unbelievably
insanely magnificent
right
like a flark and supernova so stay on
track keep your eyes open and shoot for
the stars who's with me
it's an interesting mechanic insofar as
it ties combat back to the narrative
core of the game providing a metaphor
for how being a good listener is
important for cultivating a strong
family that supports each other it's not
so interesting a wrinkle that it washes
away my problems with the rest of the
unremarkable combat though when you're
not telling your allies what to do or
propping them up you guide peter who
controls like your traditional
third-person over-the-shoulder shooter
protagonist peter can free aim or lock
into targets with his dual blasters
using his jet boots to dodge enemy
attacks there's not much to it you're
mostly just holding down the trigger and
taking the time to dodge away from an
attack or cool down your guns to keep
them from overheating but even when you
do miss a dodge you don't take much
damage and even when your guns do
overheat you don't have to wait too long
to start firing again you don't have to
think very hard as the point i'm trying
to get at the game is designed with a
focus on peter giving his allies orders
or support which ultimately ensures that
peter himself isn't all that engaging to
control in the heat of combat over the
course of the campaign you also unlock
four different kinds of elemental ammo
for peter's blasters allowing you to
unleash special attacks that can take
advantage of an enemy's weakness those
aforementioned jello monsters for
instance normal attacks don't affect
them that much but if you use ice ammo
to freeze them first they'll become
brittle and easy to destroy much like
gamora rocket tracks and groot's
abilities however the game doesn't
adequately push you to engage with these
special shots it's a mechanic that once
again is asking the player to be
strategic but then not providing any
incentive to meaningfully engage with
combat this elemental ammo alongside
your allies unique abilities also play a
role outside of combat guardians of the
galaxy features an assortment of
environmental puzzles a few of which
hide optional collectibles and cosmetics
will most simply impede progress through
a level say for one or two puzzles
however none really encourage you to
think about how to use the guardian
skills in fulfilling ways if you're
stuck in the way forward is blocked by
some pipes for example you can command
gamora to cut through them that puzzle
never becomes more complex though so
you'll just keep encountering pipes or
equivalent obstacles for her to cut
through the same can be said for all of
the different types of environmental
roadblocks you have to overcome you'll
encounter pretty much every type of
puzzle the game has within the first few
hours and then just keep stumbling upon
them
assassin calm down i'm just going to the
bathroom all paths eventually lead to
petership the in-game hub you regularly
return to between the planets that the
guardians visit it's not much of a hub
though provides opportunities to have
optional check-ins with individual
members of your crew these conversations
are largely inconsequential and lack the
emotional or narrative impact that occur
throughout the rest of the game
occasionally your time in the ship also
has you manning the helm these sections
aren't all that fun they're either
frustrating flying gauntlets where the
ship's finicky handling regularly leads
to death inducing crashes or boring
combat encounters where the simplistic
mechanics and scenarios don't create
engaging dogfights between the
irrelevant optional crew conversations
and unlikable space battles the ship
segments end up being the weakest parts
of the game on the other end of the
spectrum the soundtrack is one of the
strongest aspects of guardians of the
galaxy there are plenty of excellent
license 80s tracks sprinkled throughout
the guardians adventure to highlight
badass story or combat moments but the
original score sells the game the
thematic undertones to each world to
help differentiate the various settings
while evolutions to the score accentuate
shifts and narrative tone
marvel's guardians of the galaxy doesn't
feature an engaging combat system say
for the moments where the team huddles
provide a loose connection to the much
more engaging narrative theme of the
strength of communication the game
instead shines via storytelling which is
enhanced by a talented collection of
voice actors and a wonderful soundtrack
if this game is your introduction to the
guardians of the galaxy it's not the
best first impression but sometimes when
the galaxy needs to be saved you can
settle for good enough
and
we're laughing that's
good
it's just it's perfect
this is us this is how we push
well this is how quo parks anyways